Detroiters so this is you know what
fascinates me about this new project
Detroiters is that you've earned the
right to create this show you're you're
from Detroit and spent time there and
it's a great idea you and your co-star
play local admin not the big time admin
you you you're the guys that write the
ads that appear on the local channel
exactly like the bottom of the barrel ad
guys like we're the ones who do like
discount wigs and like you know
secondhand rugs right and you're you're
dreaming you're dreaming of being Don
Draper one day but right now this is
what you're doing and it sounds to me
like this is based on personal
experience similarly we based this show
on like it's the idea that's love that
we had of local TV show of local
commercials that we grew up watching
they're like so iconic to us and so like
we just like like I think everybody in
Detroit like knows those commercials so
well and so and so uh so do we of course
there was a you were a kid fascinated
you one that was like my absolute
favorite it was for deitrick firs mm-hmm
and it like this commercial had like
this real soft focus and it's just this
woman riding a horse in slow motion but
in a in a fur coat and that's just a
song was just like so sexy it's like
[Music]
well I heard about this just a couple
hours ago and I was I was we were just
determined to find it so he took furs
hat take a look
[Music]
[Applause]
Deitrick funny any first side of the ad
right now just say what you said I said
she's getting the gutter Detroit
[Applause]
horsey horsey get outta here
Detroit's beautiful
you